well every year since 2009 the anna
pollock of skyer award has been given to
a woman who has defended women's human
rights in a conflict zone it bears the
name of the campaigning russian
journalist who was murdered in moscow in
2006. this year's recipient is fawzi
kufi an afghan politician and activist
who was a member of the delegation
negotiating peace with the taliban
before they ultimately seized control of
the country and i'm delighted to say
that we can speak to her now thanks very
much for being with us on sky news and
congratulations um i don't want to
embarrass you
but our special correspondent alex
crawford
described you and anna as stunning
examples of humankind alex said you are
a woman of extraordinary bravery who has
survived two assassination attempts and
has proved to be an inspiration to both
women and men inside and outside her
homeland
it is
remarkable what you have been achieving
what was it like to receive this award
thank you um
at this stage or at these times where
women of understand
the encouragement the recognition and
the solidarity and support more than any
other times that uh because they are
undergoing extremely difficult
times and extremely difficult challenges
for what they have experienced for the
operation i think it goes to the bravery
and recognition of those women basically
i it gave me more power
uh and more
determination uh to move forward because
i think that these are these times
people of afghanistan in general and the
women in particular
really really need that international
space and also that solidarity because
you have just seen what happened in one
of the provinces of afghanistan every
day people are undergoing catastrophic
situation
yeah i mean just seeing that report
must really make you worry now about
afghanistan descending in into chaos and
violence
yes um i mean
stability is not just silencing the guns
it's beyond that it's about justice it's
about inclusion it's about
representation it's about people people
feeling safe and secure and dignified um
over the past 40 days relatively
security situation have not been making
headlines and i have been hearing a lot
of people globally international leaders
that i meet um they tell me that it's
relatively secure or stable but for me
that's not stability and plus in
addition to that you have just heard
about the horrible attack which targets
the civilians it's endless and it's
heartbreaking jonathan it's
heartbreaking for us who have basically
we are born
in war and we will some of us die in war
how long how long should the people of
afghanistan actually pay this price i
think it's the crime
for all of us as international community
and as a global community rather
to act together um uh in the face of
what's happening in afghanistan and
listen to the people of afghanistan in
this in this case yeah and you've been
very critical of course
of the manner of the withdrawal um by
western troops you were shot by the
taliban
um but you still sat down with them to
try
to negotiate um what are your fears now
for women and girls in the country
well the reason i actually wanted to
negotiate with them was uh to make them
understand that afghanistan has
transformed that woman and the younger
generation of afghanistan are part of
that transformation and unavoidable uh
partners you know generation of the
society that cannot be avoided they need
to the taliban in this case need to
listen to the people of ramadan and
accept the fact that they can live only
with you know tolerance and coexistence
we could form a political settlement the
taliban would have been one
uh element of that but of course there
were other political and social groups
and religious minorities and women that
could live together however
was managed and the fact that the
taliban basically expanded by their
military strategy and favored that over
a political settlement we are now in a
very in a situation of complete
lawlessness because they have formed
a so-called government on the basis of
nothing there is no legitimacy no woman
no religious minorities and this is what
is after 20 years again for me to talk
about basic rights the rights to be able
to appear in public without fail the
right to go to school and the right to
be able to you know demand um uh respect
is of course again heartbreaking my
heart really leads when i still after 20
years go to zero location and demand the
things that i took it for granted in the
past 20 years i only hope that
the international community
especially the superpowers would have
managed this withdrawal in a different
way which
certainly the resulting difference
um one of the other
rights that you've fought for is freedom
of uh the press and of course we've
heard today that two journalists have
won the nobel peace prize for for their
courageous fight for a free press and
there is a link uh dmitry muratov was
anna's editor you must be delighted for
him
i am because i know that the media
in case of my country played an
enormously important role in
enlightenment of the society and i know
that anna also spent
basically her life and also dedicated
her life her words were so strong that
um resulted her uh
voice to be silent but still
the path continues and today uh on the
15th years of anniversary of her death
and her mother
you know her the same
newspaper and editorial god's
recognition of one of the prestigious
nobel peace prize that means that um the
struggle will continue no matter if
individuals are alive or not this is a
path
that will make
people with common principles to cross
this path at some point somewhere in
this world and i'm delighted to be part
of this
struggle and part of this recommendation
well congratulations uh once again uh
and uh uh uh uh it's uh great that your
uh important work has been uh has been
uh uh uh rewarded in this way fawzia
kufi great to speak to you thank you